so by now you've probably met Alexa
Amazon's fun if occasionally not so
bright voice assistant lives in speakers
smaller speakers battery powered
speakers your phone and maybe even your
car all those gadgets have one thing in
common the only way to interact with
Alexa is to talk to Alexa but now
Amazon's giving its assistant a face
this lump of a thing is the echo show
the new $230 gadget from Amazon its
Alexa with the touchscreen that means
you can still do all of the standard
Alexa things you can set timers by stuff
on Amazon play music buy more stuff on
Amazon answer simple questions and buy
more stuff on Amazon if you don't look
at the echo show while you're talking to
it you'll use it just like a normal echo
that's good and bad by the way Alexa is
really good at a lot of things but it
can also be kind of dumb sometimes sorry
I'm not sure about that it knows the
latest Bruno Mars song is that's what I
like but can't figure out which Beatles
album came first here's the latest album
by the Beatles the screens job is to
constantly add to what you're asking for
or to what Alexa is showing you if you
play a song the echo show will show
lyrics on its 7-inch screen if you set a
timer it'll show you the timer have you
ever tried to order shoes on an echo
it's weird on the show you can actually
see what you're buying and make sure
you're choosing the right thing having a
screen and a camera also lets Alexa do a
bunch of new things too it's a really
good smart home controller for one thing
you can also watch videos on YouTube or
TV shows through Amazon just by asking
for what you want it's really cool when
it works but it doesn't always work how
can it possibly know which kitten video
I want to watch you can also use the
show for video chat with anyone who has
an echo device or even just uses the
Alexa app there's also the slightly
creepy drop in feature but I can't
imagine ever really using that you
should be really careful and think long
and hard before you put a camera like
this into your house but personally it
doesn't really bother me
for me the echo has always been most
useful in the kitchen and the echo show
is very much the same way I can look up
a recipe and actually keep it in front
of me while I work I can set a bunch of
timers and then convert cups to
tablespoons because I can't find my
measuring cups a lot of developers are
going to build really cool
video apps and who knows what else to
work on this device that's front and
center in your house an echo with the
screen is a really cool idea but there
are a few things Amazon did here that I
just don't like I mean look at the thing
itself can you imagine this in your
super minimalist HGTV kitchen no the
screen doesn't move either which might
make it hard to see and use from certain
angles and though it is a touchscreen
you're not really supposed to use it
that way the actual interface on the
thing is sparse and sort of confusing I
keep wanting to use it like a tablet
because it basically is a tablet but
Amazon just wants you to talk to the
echo show it can get kind of confusing
still the echo show is a really useful
device especially if you're already in
Alexa person one word of warning though
don't put this thing near your bed
because sometimes the screen comes on
for no reason and it is bright but in
your kitchen or in your living room this
is the most versatile and useful version
of Alexa yet it's not much to look at
but it's beautiful on the inside and
that's really what counts
you